today i'm going to cancel ryan reynolds
um and
in some ways i hate to do it to be
honest because
prior to his cancellation he probably
would have been considered one of the
last
universally liked and likable
celebrities and there's not a lot of
them left we've got regis
well he and he just died so we lost him
alex trebek is battling cancer
um who else is there besides them there
was probably a time when you would have
said i don't know will smith but then he
went off on the scientologist deep end
so
he's out the rock maybe but he he's been
canceled a few times recently i don't
remember why but i know he has been
um you know tom hanks has gotten too
political who else is there
denzel i guess keanu reeves betty white
a lot of people like
is that it are we down to them
uh well reynolds is off the list now
unfortunately canceled because of this
reynolds has apologized
because he got married to blake lively
at a former slave plantation eight years
ago
speaking to uh fast company this is what
reynolds says as he
groveled and wept presumably he said
it's something we'll always be deeply
and unreservedly sorry for
it's impossible to reconcile we saw at
the time what we saw at the time was a
wedding venue on pinterest
what we saw after was a place built upon
devastating tragedy
years ago we got married again at home
but shame works in weird ways a giant
effing mistake like that
can either cause you to shut down or it
can reframe things and move you into
action
if it doesn't if it doesn't it doesn't
mean you won't f up again
but re-patterning and challenging
lifelong social conditioning is a job
that doesn't end
okay first of all he deserves to be
canceled just for using the word
re-patterning
that's definitely not a real world word
but it's exactly
the kind of jargon that i'm sure
therapists in hollywood use all the time
re-patterning second
um he's canceled of course
because this is a ridiculous reason to
apology the place he got married is
called boone hall
in south carolina you could take a look
at some of the pictures here
if you're wondering why somebody would
get married here well
this is it it's just a beautiful spot
for a wedding that's all
that's why you get married there that
that's the whole reason despite its ugly
history it is now a quite beautiful
place
and that would be a quite logical reason
for a person to get married there
there's no reason for an apology
so what exactly is the thought process
here you can't get married at a place
where bad things happened 150 years ago
and is it just slavery what if other
kinds of bad stuff happened
what if you're getting married in an old
mansion that's now a wedding venue but
it used to be owned by a rich guy who
beat his wife
can you get married there how far does
this go
and how much research are you expected
to do into the history of a place
before choosing it as a wedding venue
how far back do you need to go
and is it just weddings can you can you
live in a place where bad stuff happened
i've lived in some very old houses uh in
the you know
in my life some going back nearly to
slavery times
was i supposed to check to see if if
slaves were once kept in that house
and why what what is the reason for that
is the land cursed is this some kind of
superstition where there's like there's
some kind of residual evil
left over and lurking um
if you're not superstitious and and you
don't believe that a per
a place can be cursed because of events
that occurred there a long time ago
then what is the issue it's just a place
it was used once for one thing which was
evil
now it's used for something else which
is good
i don't see the problem by the way if
we're ruling out all places
where there were one slaves that pretty
much means we're all gonna have to live
work and get married in antarctica
that's that's that kind of is all we've
got left
left maybe uh some spots like in the
middle of the desert in australia
maybe there um maybe the top of of mount
everest
and certainly anywhere in the ocean you
know if you want to just float out into
the middle of the ocean
make sure you're not on an old route
where slave ships used to sail but other
than that you know
um and i mean you don't want to stop on
any on on any islands unless they're
uninhabited so
i guess there are a few options i i
guess i'm not being totally fair here
there are a few places
you've got antarctica mount everest
middle of the ocean
deserted islands and deserts that's five
places
not too bad and antarctica i guess could
be a lovely place for a wedding
it might be a little cold for the doing
the wedding the the photo shoot and all
that but yeah
that's completely reasonable isn't it
nothing wrong with that
no there is something wrong with it and
uh to apologize for that
is cowardly and ridiculous and uh
many other things so brian reynolds
unfortunately is
canceled for that and it goes without
saying everybody that was actually
offended by this
the people that precipitated this
apology
are also cancelled hey you uh
yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe
button right now do it do it right now i
thank you for your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated